The Joe Rogan Experience I've been
trying to get [ __ ] jacked these days
so it's like just fat guys like fat
guy's weight loss Journeys like they
know everything and then it's like a
muscle girl which I'm into now you know
what I mean they've created a new fetish
for me just off of [ __ ] it started
with just like instructional stuff and
now it's just like some girl who's just
[ __ ] you know crushing a watermelon
with her thighs and then dead lifting
like you know 800 pounds and I'm like
those I'm in yeah
I want those because in my mind that's
got to be there's got to be one of them
that wants to [ __ ] a fat guy to like
that straighten them out because it's
exactly you [ __ ] fat pieces like just
just pinching my tits you know what I
mean and I'm like I'm a [ __ ] little
fat fella I'm your [ __ ] Pig you know
just she's got me oinking while she's
eating my ass that's gotta exist you
know what I mean 100 and you're gonna
find her after the show that's that's
why I'm here she's gonna right now she's
got her thumbs moving gals hit me up the
DMS are are open that's girls of that
jacked have to be like really horny too
you'd think so the oh that's super
physical yeah although because you're in
the you're in Peak Physical shape so
it's like all your hormones and [ __ ]
must be firing off and I think nature
would tell you that if you're a woman
and you have to lift all this heavy
stuff then like you you're in trouble
aren't doing their job they're not
defending the village you're preparing
for war yeah so you probably all your
testosterone ramps up I don't even know
you're floating the pheromones out there
to get a warrior so you're probably the
pussy's probably a top-notch top because
if your body thinks you're in distress
oh yeah you really want to get a Mongol
to make you his wife yeah something
super [ __ ] killer Viking character
yeah but that's probably tight like a
drum too
absolutely 100 oh my God Jacob probably
lift me they could probably do deadlifts
put my dick in right clench and then
just do squats
probably possible picture it there's
like a it's a meme uh the type of men
who wear masks in their car and it is uh
a woman holding a guy up while they make
out and the guy's got his legs wrapped
around by the way I'm in
sounds awesome do you want me to keep
the wristbands on yeah yeah yeah
chalked hands like she's dead lifted oh
my God I want my dick to get chat from
the calluses I want my dick to feel like
it's you know it's been at the spa all
day like it's been completely rubbed a
new layer of skin comes off every time I
get jacked off by those like a salt
baths
100 that's what I want I didn't know
that about myself I'm in there and then
listen I'm still you find out things you
find out through the algorithm and you
know what you like until you see it no
sir I did hook up with one girl that was
like strong and I think she had that
thing going on she just kind of dm'd me
and I was like [ __ ] yeah let's get in
there and it was nice I was like going
down on her and I had like giant thighs
just wrapped around my head to the point
where I was starting to no joke I'm not
exaggerating just black like I started
seeing spots and I was like if I don't
make her come I'm going to die and there
was like a [ __ ] thrill to that there
was like it felt like Indiana Jones
sliding under the [ __ ] thing with
that you know what I mean I was like I
have moments to make this woman bust
before I lose Consciousness it was
[ __ ] thrilling yeah so I don't know
but I'll guarantee you there's a thing
like that where a woman like doesn't
even want a powerful man she just wants
a God that she could turn into a project
right because women always do that with
guys anyway sure the same type of women
that adopt like sad dogs
a lot of people they'll take on projects
with people yeah and I think Brian
Callan used to always do that okay he
used to have these guys that he would
date I'd be like Brian [ __ ] stop
interesting like it's okay you know I'm
gonna help her out and it was always a
disaster they want meth heads like wild
[ __ ] I'm ready to be someone's disaster
I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready to have a
good three months until I slip off my
diet and they're like what I found I
found a [ __ ] oatmeal cream pies in
the wrappers in the in the garbage I'm
like I don't know what to tell you babe
somebody must have broken in and had
[ __ ] a dove bar because it wasn't me
I was doing I was doing
I swear to God that was when I was doing
hot yoga babe
just kicked me out she [ __ ] I've been
there's a PS5 and she kicks it and uh
just snacks fall out of it I've taken
all the hard drive I've taken all the
games out and it's just [ __ ]
Twizzlers and [ __ ] chocolates she
finds a secret fridge filled with Coke
yeah
family heirlooms from Greece don't touch
it if you're in a relationship and you
have to hide what you actually like oh
yeah like oh man well I think part of it
is because a lot of my relationship you
know I'm big on therapy I've been
thinking about this [ __ ] all the time a
lot of my relationships what I'm into is
someone who just treats me way too good
because it's like that's my mom kind of
coddled me I was a mama's boy I was the
first born I was like a one of those
like smart precocious little kids who's
like always saying something fun right
and so every time I've really really
liked a girl to like be in a serious
relationship she's just kind of like
over the top kind of met like I wouldn't
have to hide anything because they're
like oh you can't even help it you know
and I'm like I'm sorry I can't you know
and so I think part of me wants like
yeah [ __ ] throw me through the ring
some hot mama yeah dude how much stepmom
porn is there out there there's a lot
out there it seems crazy I think it's
like what happened when did this emerge
every now and then I'll check out yeah
there's a whole different wave of genre
going on that is huge
um I don't know what it is I'm not see
that's the weird thing you would think I
would have like Mommy [ __ ] I don't have
that Mom [ __ ] is different stepmom is
like different dad is divorced but dad's
rich and Dad marriage is really hot [ __ ]
right and he's got to be at work all day
he's got a [ __ ] run the qualification
and you're this jock son in college oh
yeah that's like all of them absolutely
that sounds pretty good hey you know
what I'm in it's like a classic [ __ ]
Joseph Campbell genre yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it starts at dinner one day because no
one feels bad for anyone involved like
no one feels bad that she's cheating on
the sun the sun is in College of course
so it's that's fine the dad's dad is
probably some rich piece of [ __ ] yeah
emotionally abusive neglectful probably
cheated on his mom who was an amazing
woman and now he's with the she does the
chemotherapy maybe she wasn't there he
wasn't there he wasn't there he didn't
give a [ __ ] he was at the office no he
was at the office and now he's got this
new one exactly and she's a [ __ ]
weight lifter now yeah let's [ __ ] get
it pumps giant thighs now we're getting
into what I'm liking she comes into my
room she's like why haven't you done
your homework I'm like you're not my
real mom she's like what the [ __ ] did
you say to me shoves me picks me up
against the wall and that's now we're
talking and then you lean towards and
she just goes for it she starts making
out yeah yeah oh my God yeah she holds
you up with one arm where she's grabbing
your dick with the other one oh just
joking crazy yeah oh my God
it doesn't let me come the first time
she's like finish your homework maybe
you'll bust next time I'm like yes ma'am
oh wow I'll become a model student I'm
in a little tie shooting Ty oh hello
father dude we might just created the
new genre of porn It's gotta It's gotta
Advance female trainer like muscular the
thing is like how many like really
jacked muscular females go into porn
true they're probably a very small very
small minority I've done the research
it's not that many I have jacked off to
a couple of yeah videos I don't think
that's a genre yet no but we'll get that
you have to like like get people to
train for it like Cirque du Soleil yeah
you know like get these guys going look
look there's a whole new genre right
like if porn was organized the way like
film and television was yeah yeah we
need it we need a look at this gal
holding that guy over her head holy [ __ ]
look at the size of her how is that how
big is that dude he's a little guy but
bro she looks like she's got some
[ __ ] stock genetics oh yeah like that
will make you a barbarian I mean that
guy's a warrior that guy's foot could
fit in her [ __ ] look at the size of her
[ __ ] legs her ass muscles the way
she's hoisting that guy one arm over her
head let's just assume he's a tiny guy
tiny he's got to weigh a hundred pounds
let's say five to 100 pounds even if
he's do a hundred pounds over your head
with one arm like that it's crazy yeah
and the fact that it's this woman who's
very womanly when is this from 19th
century muscle women I was looking at
other pictures and just saw that one bro
that is 100 like Viking genetics right
yeah a hundred percent oh you got two
little guys two little guys with one arm
over her head and that's the thing no
one could you weren't allowed to jack
off to stuff you know plainly this
couldn't be a sex thing but this was 100
a sex thing back then look at the size
of her and she's holding three guys on
her arms what did she do this seems like
the same lady this is a genre
lost to history no offense this long
since past woman yeah but she has a very
masculine face she does that easily
could be a guy that sells you I.T
service right
how many gigabytes you guys think you
use oh you don't need that upload speed
you guys are fine where you're at go
back to that I don't like when I say
this but you guys are that person is
that same person come on man that's that
I mean initially could be a guy who
works at Google you have to throw a vest
on her yeah like a a stout guy too look
how Stout she looks yeah because she's
got the corset who knows what she'd
actually be like look at the [ __ ]
guns on that lady oh yeah dude oh my God
you like that hahaha